Jujutsu Kaizen just went too far man
this was actually insane we thought we
were watching a funny meme fight but
that twist in the end literally just
turned the entire jjk story upside down
the main villain of the story is dead
and the one who will take his place as
the final villain could be Yuji himself
we have to talk about this right now you
guys know how this works if you enjoy
our jjk content and you want to see more
in the future leave a quick like and
comment for that YouTube algorithm and
if you want to help this channel attain
special grade status by hitting million
subscribers do me a big favor and
subscribe right now we are so close
finally this video will of course
contain jjk manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned it's already been five chapters
since the main focus of the story
shifted from the big fight against
sukuna to kenju and his mission to
eliminate a bunch of smaller culling
game players this shift in Focus
eventually led to multiple chapters that
focused exclusively on the meme battle
between kenak Quin takaba now to be
honest this fight is actually very
entertaining and parts of it were really
funny personally I loved all the random
references to things like Yu-Gi-Oh and
the isekai trun and if this fight was
happening at any other point in the
story it wouldn't be so controversial
but it has been very controversial
because a lot of fans are upset that we
went from witnessing epic battles
between some of the strongest Sorcerers
in the world like Gojo and sukuna to a
standup comedy meme fight between Kaku
and takaba if you are part of the jjk
phandom and you've been checking social
media lately then you know how toxic the
debates have been but gig trolled
everyone again because chapter 243 just
went sio mode and absolutely shocked
everyone The Twist at the end was pure
insanity and with just a few quick
panels gag completely changed the
trajectory of the entire jiujitsu Kaizen
story this is even bigger and even
crazier than it seems and the
implications for yuji's future in
particular could be catastrophic don't
forget to like And subscribe if you
believe in the power of trun now let's
get back into it on an important thing
that we recently learned about takaba
curse technique is that it doesn't just
create Illusions and then compel his
opponents to participate in the illusion
no it actually integrates the opponent's
very thoughts as feedback and kenju
believes that the power takaba uses is
actually Soul resonance this is very
important and in chapter 243 the comedy
meme battle between kenju and takaba
finally ends takaba is sad that his
dream is coming to an end and he thanks
Kaku for the fun he was able to have
Kenny smiles and says that takaba is
actually pretty funny and it seems that
kenju had a lot of fun as well in fact
the meme fight was the most fun he's had
in centuries let's be real he was loving
every moment of it but then suddenly
just as it seems like old man Kenny
outsmarted everyone yet again Utah
appears behind kenju and attacks him so
quickly that Kaku is unable to counter
as a result Kaku is suddenly relieved of
his head Utah seem seemingly just
defeated Kenny with a ninja tier
surprise attack but he was only able to
sneak up on Kaku because of the effects
of takaba curse Technique we know that
takaba technique has the ability to
miraculously heal the user's body
without the use of reverse curse
technique and it can also conjure up a
bunch of different things but one thing
that it can't do is kill an opponent now
I'm not sure if this is because the
curse technique can't take someone's
life or if it's because takaba as a
person just refuses to kill whatever the
case may be takaba curse technique seems
to have the power to affect an
opponent's very soul and when Once Soul
itself is being affected and manipulated
they can't function at 100% they can't
be as aware as cautious and as quick as
they normally are and that is exactly
what UTA was able to exploit takaba
couldn't kill Kaku but he did just
enough to allow the overpowered UT to
sneak up on him and take him out before
Kenny could realize what was even
happening and yet that is not the end of
Kaku at least not yet before he dies our
boy Kenny says that it's a shame that he
got bested and killed now that he was
almost at the point of accomplishing his
master plan but it's all good anyway
because someone else will inherit his
will someone else will continue where
Kaku left off but who is this person and
why is it Yuji I'll talk about that in a
second but first is this really the end
for Kenny is this really the last time
we're going to see pretty much the main
villain in the jjk story and the one
person whose master plan has been
guiding everything that has happened in
the story up to this point well as we
know from the you should have gone for
the head rule of jiu Jutsu Kaizen losing
one's head does normally mean that a
person in question will inevitably die
and I mean if Gojo supposedly died
without even losing his head then
freaking kenju better not survive this
although to be honest I am still hoping
that Gojo will be back somehow I know
you guys are making fun of me in the
comments as we speak but I don't care I
will never stop the cope anyway I'm
happy that Gojo got his revenge because
one of his best students just took Kaku
out the only thing that gives me pause
is kaku's extremely weird cursed
technique he's basically just that brain
parasite thing anyway and ghetto body
was already dead when he possessed it so
potentially the parasite could survive
at least for a limited amount of time
even after the host body is killed what
do you guys think is Kaku dead or is he
alive make your choice down in the
comments right now but okay let's assume
that Kenny's death isn't a fake out and
that he really won't survive this what
does the comment about his will being
inherited by someone else really mean
and what will happen to his master plan
now like Kaku has a lot of moving pieces
right now he even abducted Master Tangen
so clearly a lot of wheels are in motion
will someone take over and try to finish
what Kenny started or is this the end of
his grand plan as we know it assuming
that Kenny didn't secretly have some
perfect successor villain guy just
conveniently lurking in the shadows the
most interesting twist would be one in
which the person who is destined to
somehow inherit kaku's will is none
other than his son Yuji itadori and yes
in case some of you guys forgot yuji's
literally kaku's son after Ki itadori
died Kaku possessed her body had a nice
dinner and a movie date with yuji's Dad
Jin and got pregnant with Yuji N9 months
later kenju in K's body literally gave
birth to Yuji so yeah when choso calls
Yuji his brother he's actually right
Yuji is a human experiment intentionally
created by Kaku an evil sorcerer who has
been conducting human experiments using
kurur energy for hundreds of years but
even among all the many evil human
experiments that Kenny has conducted
over the years Yuji is still special
with something like the cursed wombs
death paintings yes Kaku created them
for his own selfish purposes but he did
it by exploiting and experimenting on
other people with Yuji he took a direct
and active role in creating him he went
through the trouble of becoming his
mother carrying him for 9 months and
then giving birth to him there is no way
Kena would have done all of this if he
didn't have something very special in
mind for Yugi and since those plans have
not been revealed yet I'm inclined to
believe that Yuji might actually be the
inheritor of kaku's will now Yuji has no
idea that this is what Kaku has planned
for him and we still don't know how
Kenny's will might manifest inside of
Yuji obviously Yuji would never
willingly support Kenny's plans but
yuji's body has been clearly augmented
By kenju Yuji has always had superhuman
physical Powers he has the ability to
hurt the soul of his opponents and not
just their body and even makito
confirmed that Yuji has a unique
understanding of the human soul yuji's
body is also seemingly learning to use
sua's innate technique and Yuji might
even be be able to Soul swap which is
absolutely crazy so could it be that
Kenny has somehow manipulated Yuji from
the inside in order to ensure that
itadori becomes the inheritor of his
will did he maybe place a fragment of
himself inside of Yuji or did he imbue
him with a power that Yuji will be
unable to control and this will then
lead him to go berserk and do exactly
what Kendrick wants him to do even
though Yuji himself doesn't want to
honestly these are all such interesting
questions and the latest chapter of
Jutsu kaisen made it all a lot more
interesting for a long time I've been
wondering what exactly Kenny had planned
for Yuji and what will happen when Yuji
finally comes to the Forefront of the
story and grows into his role as the
main protagonist with this insane
game-changing twist at the end of
chapter 243 it looks like jjk is finally
about to give us the answers we need
okay seriously who is kaku's successor
the one who will inherit his will and
could it be his son Yuji let me know
down in the comments right now and and
then you can come back to the comment
section later and see if you are right
or completely wrong don't worry if
you're wrong you can always just quietly
delete your comment but I mentioned all
of my theories in the actual video so if
I end up being totally wrong about
everything everyone can come back here
and laugh at me and while you're
laughing if you're looking for an epic
jjk video to watch next don't ignore my
video about sukuna secret younger
brother link on screen and in the
description if you enjoyed this jjk
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
if you want to help this channel attain
special grade status by hitting 2
million subscribers
do me a big favor and subscribe it's
completely free and we're almost there